welcome to the fourth day of this
exciting workshop today we have team to
talk about beyond thank serious it's
actually fitting Ilyas would introduce
me because beyond words came it's case
analysis is actually sort of a
modification of an old paper of us is we
Papadimitriou called beyond competitive
analysis so so thanks everyone for
showing up early thanks to the boot camp
organizers for inviting me to come give
a talk on on a topic that's been sort of
near and dear to my heart for a while
now a circle of ideas I like to call
beyond worst-case analysis so in this
tutorial I'll try to shine a spotlight
on a lot of what I think are really cool
results in this area and the circle of
ideas many of which actually I think of
sort of flown under the radar of the
sort of mainstream algorithms community
despite being really nice results so you
know I'll try to I think they should be
more widely appreciated and then the
other thing I want to kind of highlight
is there's a ton of opportunities for
further work in this area so some really
concrete open problems about algorithms
and computational problems we all
already care about that I think are
really interesting so I'll try to
highlight those throughout as well
before at the outset I should say this
is sort of a two-hour Reader's Digest
version of a class that I've given
semi-regularly at Stanford since 2009
the vast majority of what I say today
was covered in more detail in the course
materials so there's both a full set of
lecture notes and there's a full set of
lecture videos up on YouTube so if any
of this you find cool you might want to
check that out at some point in the
future so let me start with a
clarification so sometimes you know when
I use this phrase beyond worst-case
analysis I've had people parse it this
way and have asked me so Tim so what
would be on worst mean exactly here like
terrible case analysis abysmal case
analysis so this is how I want you to
parse it so if you like think of it as
alternatives to worst case analysis so
let me start by just oh by the way feel
free to interrupt with questions at at
any time so let me begin by saying you
know what do I mean by worst case
analysis and why would you need some
alternatives ok so let's say we've
agreed on a top
no problem you know Sat TSP whatever and
suppose we've agreed on a performance
measure for an algorithm okay so the
first one you learn about as a student
is the running time but maybe it's a
heuristic for an np-hard problem and I
care about the objective function value
of the solution returned or the
approximation ratio maybe I just care
about correctness whatever so let's say
there's some performance measure you
want to say minimize the cost of some
algorithm a for this problem on some
input Z of this problem and the reason
analyzing algorithms is so hard is
because pretty much any two algorithms
you ever look like look at or in some
sense and comparable but when you talk
about the performance of an algorithm
what do you mean you really mean you
know a very rich object you mean a
vector indexed by all possible input Z
then this algorithm ever might be run on
that's the full performance profile of
an algorithm take any two algorithms
generally one of them will do better on
some of the inputs and the other will do
better on the other inputs so without
further modeling choices there's no
unequivocal way to call one of the two
algorithms better than the other you
know there is a sort of very happy but
rare exception of instance optimal
algorithms so this is problems where you
actually have a single algorithm which
is better than every other algorithm on
every other input at least up to a
constant factor and there are some
applications so the term is from Fagin
lotin and Nour they get some nice
examples in database search and there's
also been some great follow-up work and
low dimensional computational geometry
but these are really the exceptions that
prove the rule so even for problems like
sorting easy to prove there's no
instance optimal algorithm you're really
stuck with this issue that any two
algorithms are just in some sense
incomparable so how to proceed well
almost all work in algorithm analysis
proceeds by squashing this big
performance profile vector down to a
single summary statistic so to each
algorithm you attach a single number now
of course it's easy to compare different
algorithms and talk about optimal
algorithms there are some exceptions
like by jekt of analysis is a concept
which works directly with the
performance profiles themselves which
has some really nice applications in the
competitive analysis of online
algorithms you know but for the most
part almost everything in algorithm
analysis takes this approach in some way
or another so worst case analysis is
really just a modeling show
for what summary statistic you're going
to use to summarize this whole
performance profile and as it would
suggest you look at the worst of all of
the inputs so you take the maximum over
any input you might run this algorithm
on of the performance measure now
actually usually you know especially for
something like running time this isn't
gonna be a number this is going to be a
function parameter example by the input
size there may be some other parameter
but in general you know you're gonna be
taking the worst overall inputs of a
given size of that performance measure
for that algorithm so let's let's review
what we tell our undergrads when we
teach when we teach algorithms why do we
do worst-case analysis well first you
know if you have an upper bound that's
kind of utopia a good worst-case upper
bound on an algorithm means you do not
have to reason at all about the inputs
that you need to solve you need no model
of the data doesn't matter what it is
just run the algorithm you're gonna do
great
and if that seems sort of too strong to
hope for well then there's this cool
thing that actually lots of fundamental
computational problems actually admits
algorithms with really good worst-case
running times in fact almost everything
we teach an undergraduate algorithms has
this property so we can get away with it
and then of course as you know for
people in this room or actually proof
things about algorithms you know of
course it's not lost on us that it tends
to be quite a bit easier to prove things
about the worst-case performance then
about some other measure that you might
want to use okay so that's the that's
the last reason so you know so there's
lots of killer applications the
worst-case analysis but you know you go
a little bit beyond the problems that
you study in undergraduate algorithms
and you start seeing its weaknesses it
starts kind of you know having some epic
fails for more general problems so what
I want to do next is just sort of review
three of those epic fails of worst-case
analysis which isn't going to motivate
some of the other topics we discuss this
morning so they begin with maybe the
most famous failure case of worst case
analysis which concerns linear
programming so optimizing a linear
objective function subject to linear
constraints so linear programming was
you know really first generally
articulated by Danzig in the 40s and at
that same time he also proposed an
algorithm for solving linear program to
the simplex method and this kind of
blows my mind but you know here we are
70 years later and variants of the
simplex method are still the dominant
paradigm for solving linear program
in practice there are other really good
methods too but still simplex is used
more than anything else so why why so
successful well you just run it on
someone your program where you care
about the answer and it's just going to
tell you the answer really quickly what
do I mean really quickly like a typical
thing would be linear in the number of
decision variables that's observed in
practice quite a bit so that was in the
40s in the 1960s people started thinking
about worst case polynomial running time
bounds for algorithms so was natural to
wonder if there was one for the simplex
method so as a significant result by
clay and minty in the early 70s that the
answer unfortunately is no you actually
can contrive particular linear programs
that force the simplex method you know
with kind of any of the common pivot
rules to run for an exponential number
of iterations so the worst-case
performance of simplex you have to
concede is exponential just by
definition and this obviously you know
is a terrible performance prediction for
this algorithm in practice and then sort
of to add insult to injury you know
things now are different but at least
initially when the first parlament
provably polynomial time algorithms
worst case came out they were just
manifestly inferior to the simplex
method for pretty much any linear
program you'd want to solve so in
addition to just having a very for poor
performance prediction of the simplex
method in effect if you take worst-case
analysis at face value it's giving you
just really bad advice about how to
solve a linear program it's advocating
the inferior algorithm to the
empirically superior algorithm okay so
this will motivate our discussion of
smooth analysis which will be one of the
topics in part two of the tutorial so
next I want to talk about clustering so
a form of unsupervised learning and you
know I want to leave this kind of
undefined you know sort of vague for
this slide but you know you're given a
bunch of data points you know in
Euclidean space or in a metric space and
you want to somehow group the data
points coherently whatever that means so
you know points that are close to each
other typically should be in the same
cluster points that are far apart you
hope would be in different clusters so
you know this is too vague to reason
about formally so if you want to
actually you know prove guarantees for
clustering algorithms you know how would
you proceed well a very natural way to
do it and there's been a ton of work on
this is you phrase it as an optimization
problem so you posit an objective
function defined over all clusterings
and you look for the
best one according to that objective
function you've probably seen many
examples of this
you know the k-means k median case
center and so on and sort of a meta
theorem is that however you decide to
phrase up phrase clustering as an
optimization problem it's going to be
np-hard even and usually np-hard to
approximate to within sufficiently good
constants okay so it's worst case hard
even for small constant approximations
on the other hand you know this clearly
doesn't stop people from using
clustering very successfully in practice
it's very widely used algorithms even
really simple algorithms like say
k-means or k-means plus plus and you
know they don't always work great but
for most of the instances that people
care about they're really they're happy
with the results they get back clusters
which they find meaningful and
illuminate it so you know how can how
can theory sort of reconcile these two
facts you know the fact that it's worst
case hard but you seem to have
meaningful results in practice well so
there's a strand of literature which
I'll talk in much more detail about
shortly which you know can be summarized
dating nicely with the title of a paper
of Daniel e lineal and sax which is the
thesis the conjecture the clustering is
hard only when it doesn't matter so what
does that mean so you know it's an
np-hard problem so we know there are
hard instances but you know what if the
hard instances just look like a bunch of
random points in space with no really
interesting clustering you know then who
cares we're not trying to cluster random
points anyways we're trying to cluster
you know proteins or something else that
has meaning so the reason you're running
a clustering algorithm is because you
expect there actually is a good
clustering to be found so the hope would
be that if you make that assumption
explicit you assume there's a meaningful
clustering to be found that implies
additional structure on the instance
which can actually be then rigorously
leveraged by an algorithm and give you
provable guarantees better than the
worst case that's we'll see that so that
would be the first main technical topic
we discuss all right so the last failure
case somewhat I mentioned comes from
competitive analysis of online algorithm
so we've heard a lot about competitive
analysis on Tuesday from Nikhil and Adam
and also Sethi and so this is a problem
that you know that I think seve talked
about a bit online paging so you know
and this was the original online
algorithm
one proposed by Slater and Tarjan in the
mid-80s and it's familiar to anyone
who's taken and operating systems or
computer architecture class right so you
have a sort of relatively small
relatively fast memory a cache it can
hold up to say K pages and then a
sequence of page requests come in online
that is one by one okay and when a page
request shows up if that page is already
sitting in your cache great you incur no
cost if however the requested page is
not in the cache that's a page fault or
a cache miss and you have no choice but
to bring in that page into your cache
and if your cache is already full that
means you need to have it something to
make room for this new page that you're
bringing in so the algorithmic question
in online paging is which page do you
evict on a page fault okay because let
me summarize I mean you can imagine
variants of worst-case analysis which
add meaning and actually the next slide
will be exactly that kind of example not
in clustering but an online paging so
it's not to say that there aren't ways
to modify worst case analysis to
increase meaning but the the focus of
this tutorial will be on a little bit
more radical departures from the worst
case world in the spirit of meaningful
guarantees but yeah we'll see a concrete
example that on the next slide so for
paging all right so that's what you
learned the other thing you learn in
your systems classes is they basically
tell you what eviction policy you should
use or aspire toward which is least
recently used or LRU okay so this just
says you know when you have a page fault
see you know which is your most recently
unpopular page okay so the page which
most recently reserved or had requested
furthest in the past evict that and
you're also talk you're also taught the
intuition about why LRU works well in
practice which is so-called locality of
reference so this is the thesis that
which you can empirically verify
but in typical page request sequences if
a page was just requested recently it's
likely to be requested soon in the
future so in some sense the future is
going to look a lot like the past at
least the recent past and so that's why
it's advocated over other natural
eviction policies like first-in
first-out in the systems class alright
so could we develop theory which mirrors
what you know practitioners observe
about paging in practice so Slater inte
R Jen really founded the the field of
online algorithms and looked at this and
you know one early observation that they
made in their paper is that if you apply
worst-case analysis at least in the most
straightforward way to the online paging
problem it's really an epic fail in a
couple senses so what they show is that
consider any deterministic online
algorithm that you want FIFO LRU you
know other ones it doesn't matter there
will exist no matter how big your cache
sizes that will exist a page request
sequence so that your algorithm faults
100% of the time and moreover in
hindsight if you look at the optimal
thing you should have done so in this
case it's called the farthest in the
future algorithm your page fault rate
would have only been 1 over k percent so
you know K might be a thousand or 10,000
so you got a fault rate of a hundred
percent well you could have gotten
something less than 1% so in what ways
is this an epic fail the first is just
that you know it kind of you know you
never observe page fault rates
anything close to 100% from any of these
policies in practice so somehow you've
taken at face value this is this doesn't
make a lot of sense but also it fails to
differentiate between algorithms which
we kind of know are different in
practice it doesn't advocate LRU over
FIFO and actually maybe we shouldn't be
surprised about that because we're told
in systems you know why LRU beats FIFO
and it's because of a property of
typical data it's because of locality of
reference so if a model never
articulates structure in the data you
know to mirror locality of reference you
know why should we expect the theory to
separate these two algorithms actually
if you think about it okay so I'm not
gonna have time to say too much about
online paging in this tutorial but I do
want everyone to know that you know more
than any other problem I've come across
this is the failure of worst-case
analysis which led to the
most kind of introspection and
soul-searching among people who
throughout rhythmic analysis so there's
really a really nice kind of prescient
literature from the late 80s and the 90s
mostly you know about how can you dodge
you know this these worst case bounds
for paging Slater and Tarjan already had
some suggestions like resource
augmentation but there's many others as
well so I can't talk much about that
literature but I can't resist at least
mentioning sort of one result which I
like a lot due to Albers faculty and
Yale so you know as as advertised this
will still be worst case analysis but
they make two changes which which give
them really interesting results the
first thing is they focus on the page
fault rate an absolute measure rather
than the competitive ratio and you know
that's very you know if you can prove
the page fault rate is low you know
arguably you're happy no matter what the
competitive ratio is but the second
thing which here's the part I want to
emphasize is they parameterize the input
in an interesting way
now again we're used to thinking about
parameterizing the input if nothing else
by the input size but Albers at all
proposed a parameterization which is
really specific to the problem of online
paging okay so it's not a general way to
parameterize problems but it's one which
is sort of exactly what you want to get
the kind of theorem that they get to get
meaningful results about online paging
so the parameterization is through a
function f think of this as a concave
function and so we say that it's a page
request sequence so basically so
intuitively linear F's are going to
correspond the no locality of reference
and super concave FS are going to
correspond the tons of locality of
reference that's the way to think about
it so formally for any particular size W
of a window consecutive requests we say
that a sequence conforms to the function
f if there's at most f of w distinct
page requests in any window of a length
w okay most f of w different requests
for different pages in a window of
length w so if f is linear this imposes
no constraint at all okay you can just
do anything but you know you can think
about concave FS which is you know
closer to what you see in real life page
requests sequences like f being square
roots or f being a logarithmic for
example okay and so they're going to
have a worst case bound about these
paging algorithms parameterised by f
so the more locality of reference we're
looking for better performance so
there's a couple parts to their theorem
the first parts are already are very
satisfying okay so the first thing that
their theorem shows is it shows an
optimality result for LRU in a very
strong sense in a sense which is
function by function cache eyes by cache
shots so there's a parameter alpha sub F
of K I'll tell you what that is in a
second but the the first high order bit
here is that you can prove on the one
hand for X every choice of F and every
choice of W every deterministic
algorithm has worst case fault rate at
least alpha for that F and W worst case
over sequences that conform to F
meanwhile LRU again for every choice of
F and for every choice of the cache size
has a matching worst-case page fault
rate okay so that's the first thing
which is really nice LRU is somehow
optimal point wise across choices of F
and the cache size the second thing is
that actually alpha is small enough that
these results are meaningful even taken
at face value which is actually pretty
rare for sort of worst case
approximation results so I'm not going
to give you the exact formula for alpha
but you know alpha is gonna be a hundred
percent if F is linear we already knew
that but if there's some locality of
reference so like if F is the square
root function then alpha is like 1 over
the square root of the cache size 1 over
the square root of the cache size so if
your cache size is 10,000 this is saying
your worst case page fault rate is 1%
okay which sounds pretty good actually
if you know F was logarithmic it would
even be dropping exponentially fast with
K all right so those are the two first
things to notice an optimality statement
for LRU in a strong sense and just you
know performance bounds which are
interpretable you know at face value
very cool
the other thing we were sort of
complaining about on the last slide was
that the theory did not differentiate
between LRU and FIFO or for that matter
any other deterministic paging algorithm
but here you can okay so here there are
choices of F and K actually lots of
different choices will work so that for
example of the FIFO policy will not
achieve this best possible page fault
rate of alpha f of K okay
yeah there are some bounds on it so the
gap is not that big but they argue that
actually in practice the gap isn't so
big either between LRU and FIFO so maybe
it makes sense that so they can both
prove they can prove an upper bound on
FIFO which is sort of a small constant
bigger than 1 times alpha yeah again
arguably that's sort of in line with
what you see
empirically okay so I mentioned this
result for two reasons one is like I
said I mean I just I'm a fan of this
page in literature I wanted to tell you
least something about it but also you
know before we sort of depart from worst
case analysis you know a broader point I
want to make is that you know often you
can actually salvage really meaningful
results in the worst-case analysis
framework just with a smart problem
specific parameterization of the input
now you know the algorithms community
has tons of parameterised bounds of all
different types so for example in
parameterize the algorithms and
complexity you know which is very hot
right now you get lots of running time
bounds which are parameterize by for
example the size of an optimal solution
but again what I'm talking about here is
not so much generic ways of
parameterizing inputs but really
thinking about you know what is it you
want to say about the problem and about
the algorithms and then what's the
appropriate input parameterization you
know for that domain I think this is a
great sort of success story of that kind
of work and I think there's room to do
more of that in general okay so that's
what I wanted to say about worst case
analysis so how well did it do well it's
to give it grades to give it a report
card I should sort of say what what are
the subjects like what do we want to
grade it on so that means like well K
why are we doing this algorithm analysis
thing in the first place and there's a
bunch of different reasons you might you
know want a rigorous theory of algorithm
performance you know one thing that's
which is really pretty
ambitious is you might want to just
actually have accurate performance
prediction for specific algorithms for
specific problems okay and so this is a
lot of what Kevin will be talking about
in the afternoon and here with worst
case analysis you're basically not
trying to do this right so if you have
any algorithm with a large amount of
variation in performance across inputs
obviously by focusing on the worst case
you're punting on trying to predict on
typical instances it's just not what
it's meant to do now sometimes you know
if you have very little variation in
running time across instances like for
merge sort say or a lot of dynamic
programming algorithms then it's fine
you do get actually meaningful
performance predictions and again
you know for problems we teach an
undergrad algorithms that often is the
case now maybe you say okay that's
overkill I don't really care about
having sort of a literal prediction of
how good Navin is going to do but I want
to know what algorithm should I use to
solve this problem give me some advice
of how what algorithm to use so that
means you want to compare them and
ideally identify optimal algorithms and
you know here they're I think the
greatest sort of mixed there's problems
like you know the ones we teach the
undergrad a LaRue or worst case analysis
gives you great practical advice about
how to solve things you know mergesort
Dijkstra with heaps etcetera but as
we've seen in these preceding examples
it starts breaking down and you start
getting inaccurate advice about how to
solve problems more generally and then
the third thing which you know we
shouldn't forget is you know there's
other reasons to have a formal sort of
benchmark you know yardstick by which
you judge algorithms better or worse you
know if nothing else you know for people
who work in algorithms and direct
computer science if you posit some
yardstick by which you know smaller
numbers are just better the club have
Lobby and responsive everybody is to
just you know brainstorm like crazy and
try to come up with you know crazy new
algorithms that do better than the state
of the art and so worst-case analysis
clearly has been incredibly successful
as sort of a brainstorm organizer so
there's literally thousands of new
algorithms which I really think probably
would not have been invented if we
didn't have this this framework to think
about you know it's and it's some of
these algorithms not practical that
doesn't matter a lot of the ideas are
relevant and a lot of the algorithms are
practical as well okay so I've just
basically reviewed you know the
well-known reasons why we don't always
want to do worst-case analysis obviously
when it's wrong it's because it's overly
pessimistic you can get bad advice about
what algorithm to use and you know and
the pros I said a probe worst-case
analysis is that there's no data model
that's true when you have a good upper
bound you know but when it's not working
out then it actually seems like a con
that you don't have a data model in
worst-case analysis or if you have a
data model into the Murphy's Law data
model it's a Murphy's Law says whatever
can go wrong will go wrong and so a
worst-case analysis as a philosophy is
saying I believe the relevant input is a
function of the algorithm that I choose
right now
which maybe there's some cryptographic
applications would that make sense but
in general it's kind of a paranoid and
incoherent way to think about solving
problems okay so the point being is what
does it really mean that go beyond
worst-case analysis for this tutorial
what it's going to mean is that you need
to actually commit you need to
articulate some property of the data so
you need to somehow deem some inputs
more relevant than others now there's
many ways of doing that all right so
just like an algorithm design right
there's no silver bullet
there's no one out rhythmic idea which
like is a panacea for all your
algorithmic ills so there's not going to
be an algorithm analysis you know one
magical notion of data which works well
for every problem but just like an
algorithm design there's a bunch of
tools there's a bunch of things that are
starting to work repeatedly and that's
what I want to expose you to for the
rest of this tutorial
okay so we're through the first half of
part 1 roughly so I told you what
worst-case analysis is and why we might
want to do something different
the next part I'm going to sort of tell
you about some of the theory around
making precise this conjecture the
clustering is hard only when it doesn't
matter and then I'm going to try to
convince you that actually a lot of work
in sparse recovery for example and
compressive sensing is really
technically kind of exactly the same
spirit of this work in part three so any
questions before I move on
you didn't mention that Oh randomized
them for paging you mean or for what or
for anything yes so I mean randomized to
the randomized algorithms were just
coming in the very first slide where you
talk about the performance measure so if
there's randomized you could say the
expected cost over the coin flips with
the algorithm or whatever yeah so the
formalism is fine for its you're right
that I'm not sure we'll actually see a
single randomized algorithm in this in
this talk but there's no reason why all
of these issues are I mean they're
equally well defined and meaningful for
randomized algorithms I'd say it sort of
is worst case right because the
randomization is only over the internal
coin flips so the way I would talk about
randomized Prime maladies I would say
here you care about correctness right so
I want to give an instance you either
you know you either get a correct or you
don't get it correct and that
performance measures then going to be
the probability that you're incorrect
and that's the thing that you want to
minimize over all inputs but it's still
you know if I gave you two different
randomized primality algorithms you know
some of which had a higher error rate on
some inputs and the other one had a
higher e other rate on other inputs you
know it's not clear which one to prefer
so the issue I would argue is the same
that's a part two sorry I meant to
mention that so so all of the rest of
the tutorial will be these ideas of how
do you articulate you know relevance for
data the difference between the two
parts is in part one there will not be
any distributions so we'll be looking at
deterministic conditions which are
intended to impose you know kind of
meaning on the incidence part two will
be all about probabilistic models I'll
say very little about sort of standard
average case analysis but I'll say a lot
about kind of robust versions of average
case analysis yeah totally part two
yes
all right so clustering is hard only one
it doesn't matter what does that mean
well there's actually been at least five
different proposals of how to define
instances that have a meaningful
clustering I don't have time to tell you
all five let me tell you briefly about
two of them the two that have been
studied the most so the first the first
definition and the one you know it's
really kind of in large part kicked off
the the work in this area was by Balkin
Blum and Gupta and it's a note they call
their notion approximation stability
okay so let me tell so again what is the
point of this the point is this to
define instances with meaningful
clusterings then we can ask is it easier
to solve clustering on those instances
than in worst case instances okay so
we're doing the definition first what
does it mean that you have a meaningful
clustering and this is easiest to
understand with a picture so imagine so
again we're thinking about clustering
imagine you posited some objective
function you know whatever you care
about say K median for concreteness so
on the one hand you know if you could
solve your optimization problem exactly
you would get some optimal clustering of
the points and let's assume that you
know this is the target clustering this
is the meaningful clustering that you
want your algorithm to recover okay so
we have a bunch of data points we have
three different clusters the red one the
blue one and the green one now k medians
gonna be np-hard so you're probably
gonna be running some heuristic some
approximation algorithm for the comedian
problem and here's what you're hoping
happens again you know you might not get
the optimal clustering back because it's
an np-hard problem but you're gonna get
something that has you know objective
function value close to optimal you know
within a factor 2 or whatever of the
optimal K median objective function
value and you're really hoping that what
that to approximate clustering looks
like is something like this ok so you've
noticed that a couple of the blue points
have been stolen by the green cluster
same thing with the red cluster but you
know these clusterings are very close to
each other you basically discover the
same grouping of the points into three
groups as you did before okay modulo a
few a few mistakes what you're really
hoping doesn't happen is something like
this that you run your approximation
algorithm is it to approximation
algorithm so you get a clustering with K
meeting objective within a factor two of
the smallest possible and yet if you
look structurally at the clustering you
get back it is
missing the points okay so it took the
blue and the red cluster made them one
cluster and then fractured this green
cluster into two to make up for it okay
so if you're running an approximation
algorithm on a clustering instance that
has a meaningful clustering you're
hoping to get this you're hoping you
don't get this
so approximation stability just says
let's assume that you only get this so
consider an instance so there's gonna be
a parameter alpha consider an instance
where any alpha approximate clustering
with respect to an objective function
like k median any alpha approximate
clustering actually is structurally
almost the same as the target clustering
so really there's a second parameter
here in epsilon which is how four how
different these two things can be but
I'm gonna suppress that question that's
actually not important so what you do
need to assume is that the target
clustering doesn't look too different
from the optimal solution so the
assumption is that if you optimize the
objective function you get back a
clustering that classifies 1 minus
epsilon fraction of the points the same
as your target clustering no so every
optimal solution if you like should be
within you know classify 1 minus Epsilon
the same as the target so I assume
there's only one target you don't so
this is not efficiently checkable
condition that does not mean this is not
interesting results okay so you know so
obviously it's only better if you can
efficiently check the condition but you
know I'm pretty happy if there's some
sort of plausibility argument that you
know real-world datasets might at least
approximately conform to whatever
definition you wrote down now you know
you're taking out you taking it on faith
there's no question and then ultimately
you just have to answer it with like
that were you happy with the clustering
is you got back from your algorithm or
not yeah so there's neither of these two
conditions going to be checkable yeah
kind of assuming that the problem is not
really hard hey that's exactly the
question good question so it's not clear
okay and actually it depends a little
bit with the problem exactly you know so
it's it's not obvious whether or not
making this assumption you know it's not
going to get harder but it's not clear
whether it makes it easier or leaves it
the same okay it might you're absolutely
right that it seems like it could make
it easier and that will be the fear of
encoding the assumption that you're
trying to say that clustering is only
hard in cases that don't matter but
you're kind of throwing away those cases
anyway by thinking that's right so I
guess it's sort of more like a contra
positive it's saying whatever clustering
matters it's actually easy that's the
way to think about it okay so this is
like this this is how we're defining you
know when clustering matters and again
there's there's at least four other
definitions it's not to say this is the
only reasonable one but it is it is a
good one it's not even clear how to
define cover everything yeah and again
you know you can't expect like a silver
bullet I mean it's not gonna happen
right so really we need a toolbox of
definitions and sort of ways of sort of
thinking and analyzing about problems so
that you can try out okay just like an
algorithm design neither you need a
suite of things to try sure if you like
then now it's a I don't know it just
there was a problem is we we kept all
the more points because we believe
they're all purpose importantly
something that it's okay to have some
personal points are like ice I mean the
epsilon here is only making the
assumption weaker right I mean so I'm
saying you know if so the hope so how do
you should you think about this this
assumption is basically saying numerical
closeness numerical closeness in the
objective function value translates to
structural closeness okay and the bigger
you take epsilon the weaker that
assumption is right so the more sort of
structural non closeness I'm permitting
so you know I it's not I mean I wouldn't
I wouldn't make the connection
necessarily that epsilon in the outliers
it's really just a way of making it a
more meaningful condition that's more
likely to hold for datasets it's a
definition so I mean it you know it
means when you pass to you know
approximate solutions the you know so
basically think about this way we're
passing from an optimal solution to an
approximately optimal solution and we
want the clustering that you get back to
be stable in the sense that changes very
little so that's the sense of the word
stability and so this is not stable
right so this is you know you change a
little bit in the objective function
value but actually the clustering
changes a lot
okay so that's unstable good so there's
a lot of nice work and approximation
stability let me just kind of mention
you know the main result from the Vulcan
Blum Guth the paper again there's lots
of analogous results now for other
problems so they think about K median
the community objective function and
they look at a alpha alpha approximation
stable instances where alpha for them
can be as small as you want okay so can
be any constant one point one for
example would be a reasonable thing to
set alpha to and then and again remember
this is our thesis clustering is hard
only when it doesn't matter we're
defining when it matters as being alpha
approximation stable and now we want to
prove the clustering is easy and indeed
ball cannot all prove that so they say
if you have a comedian instance which is
for example one point one approximation
stable they
in polynomial time you can recover a
clustering of the points which agrees
with the target clustering except on a
of epsilon fraction of the points okay
and what's really interesting about this
is you know alpha you know I said you
can take alpha equal to one point one
there are not one point one
approximation algorithms for the K
median objective in the worst case okay
so we're sort of below the approximation
threshold and yet it really is true that
what you impose this sort of existence
of meaningful clusters actually you're
not in the worst case instance you have
extra structure and this is a proof that
you can in polynomial time identify and
exploit that structure yes I yeah I mean
so I was glossing over the rug so I said
you know you can in poly time we recover
a clustering which misclassifies an O of
epsilon fraction of the points and in
that Big O is the gap is alpha minus one
so as you take alpha to one the number
of misclassified points is going to be
blowing up approximations stable
instance yes so so you're kind of saying
like when it's nice for metric a median
in one sense it's also nice in another
sense yes do you see what that feels
like that like well so the first sense
is okay so I mean really what this is
trying to do is it's trying to translate
from the language of approximation
algorithms which talks about how close
you get the optimal for an objective
function to the kind of guarantee you
want in a clustering setting which is
much more about classification error and
in general if you just you know
approximately solve some K meeting
objective you're not going to have small
classification error you're gonna get
just a clustering which is very
different than what you want and so the
this hypothesis is a way to sort of
bridge those two worlds it says well
let's suppose we actually have an
optimization problem which is a good
proxy of the structural problem and now
you know does that change the complexity
of the problem
and it does in a sense the question
there's there a way that this could fail
like yes there are other problems for
which you know asserting upper alpha
approximation stability does not change
change the regime in which you can
recover good clusterings sure I mean
yeah so basically sometimes you can just
have an empty hardness reduction where I
take a worst-case instance and then I
output you know an instance which sort
of the objective function values are
preserved of everything but I also have
the approximation stability so sometimes
even hard instances can satisfy all four
approximation stability and there are
examples K median is obviously not an
example and there are other not there
are there examples where you have
theorems like this as well no no the
assumption more comes from like you know
suppose it was actually useful to have
an alpha approximation algorithm in the
sense that it gives you Backa clustering
with small classification error that's
the assumption so I'll get that there's
an interesting theorem is to understand
how these types of alpha is compared to
you know these kinds of approximation
factors that'll be one of my open
questions that's a good question
for this particular result it is a
little bit tailored to it so and that's
one of the reasons why I'm not going to
talk about the proof of this the thing I
will talk a bit about the proof it's
actually just a very general purpose
algorithm and the stability condition is
only using the analysis to prove that it
works so you know to get the ball
rolling I think it's totally appropriate
to you know use the assumption but
ultimately you really want to use the
assumption only in the analysis in my
opinion not in the design framework
extent to identity heart problems or is
this something very special about
clustering the definitions or the
theorems
I'd say the definition makes sense
whenever you have a notion of stroke
structural closeness of different
feasible solutions that's really the
point right so we so we have a lot we
have tons of numerical objective
functions depending on the problem you
may or may not have a notion of like the
distance between two different solutions
but if you do then there's an obvious
analog of this definition now then
there's a question of do you have this
positive result and even within
clustering the answer is sort of depends
on the problem so there it's it's much
more back to for every problem you need
to kind of understand it or new so you
let you look at what I'm calling the
classification error so you look at you
look at the grouping of points in the
target clustering and then you look at
the grouping of points in this
clustering and you see what fraction of
points are in a different cluster in the
two clusterings so this so this is meant
to have sort of very small
classification error and this has quite
large I'd be surprised if you got
anything in that set that doesn't feel
like the kind of problem where you get
mileage out of this and and perhaps
backed up by that I haven't seen any
work on it so yeah so there's gonna be
you know so again you know we're gonna
see lots of different ways of sort of
imposing structure on on the inputs and
you know not none of them are going to
work on even a majority of the problems
that you care about right just like no
AfriNIC technique works on a majority of
the problems that you care about so you
know the the fact that there are success
stories on important problems I think is
sufficient justification you know so we
care about comedian we care about
clustering this is a novel positive
result which you know I think I think
it's worth appreciating yeah okay so
well here's what I see a little bit how
I understand it can you explain why it's
wrong it seems like
saying okay say that I have an
approximation algorithm that works so
the the notion of works is different in
the two senses so the first notion of
works is works means with respect to the
numerical objective function you're
close to optimal the second sense of
works is in terms of classification
error with respect to a target
clustering you get most of the points
correct an opera Ori there is no
relationship really between those two
objectives so anytime you can establish
a link that doing not doing well for one
of those metrics does well on the other
that's automatically interesting because
it's often not true there are results on
k-means and k-means I think case Center
I think maybe it doesn't work yeah so it
works for K k-means but not for K Center
okay so let me let me talk a little bit
about this the other stability notion so
this is called this so this was proposed
by Bill you and lineal in the context of
maxcut gamma perturbation stable so
again let me explain it with a picture
say for maxcut so here's the maxcut
instance pretty obvious what the maxcut
is this is what it is now suppose I
perturb the edge weights and actually
here's how I want you to think about
these perturbations right so first of
all suppose I'm suppose I made a pretty
mild assumption about an optimization
problem that the optimal solution was
unique one different way of that it's
saying that assumption would be well if
I make tiny perturbations to the
objective function the optimal solution
doesn't change that's the same thing as
uniqueness so perturbation stability is
just kind of uniqueness on steroids
it says not only does the optimal
solution not change into small
perturbations it doesn't change even
under somewhat big perturbations so
gamma here is going to be a constant you
know hopefully not too far from one and
we're going to think about you know
taking the weights of a maxcut instance
and multiplying each one by some number
between 1 and gamma okay so for example
let's think about gamma equal to so I
want to say that no matter how I perturb
these edge weights multiplying each by
their own factor between 1 & 2 I want
the maximum cut to stay the same you
actually if you think about it if
there's going to be any perturbation we
dislodges the optimal solution it's kind
of obvious which one it is right if I
wanted to make it least likely for the
optimal to stay the same
I would not scale up any of the edges
it's already cutting and for the edges
that it's not cutting I would scale them
up as much as I'm allowed by gamma so if
gamma equals two this is the worst
perturbation and the max cut stays the
same okay so that's the definition of
perturbation stability so it's for
problems where you have either you know
graphs and edge weights or where you
have a metric so a distance function
between points and it says the optimal
solution remains invariant as you
perturb all of the input coefficients by
factors between 1 and gamma you can have
a version with an epsilon like with
approximation stability but let's just
assume epsilon equals zero and the
optimal solution really stays the same
like motivation at distance is often
heuristics in terms of that doesn't need
that the like effective motivation the
distances maybe you know but you're
hoping you would be fulfilled right so
you mean thanks to the question I meant
to elaborate on this so like the Balkan
and all result the with what's being
done here is taking a usually implicit
assumption you know when you're hoping
your algorithm actually works in
practice and making it explicit and then
investigating theoretically you know
what does that imply about the instances
it's a different implicit assumption
here than before so here the you know
they were motivated by you know sort of
distance measures so like you have
proteins and you have a notion of
protein similarity you know and then
when you do some say like clustering or
partitioning algorithm with respect to
that distance function you're really
hoping that you don't get back an answer
which is kind of an artifact of the
details of your distance function you're
really hoping there's sort of a robust
solution like robust clustering which
even if you had the distances a little
bit wrong you'd still get it back now
that's not going to be true in general
right in general Mis specification does
totally change what you get back but
this and you know let's think about the
sort of regime where you're implicitly
assuming that it works how do you write
that down as a definition what
implications does that have for the
complex there's a problem okay so that's
MIT so there's been there's been nice
work on maxcut I want to tell you
actually a little bit about a different
results again but about perturbation
stability which is the multi way cut
problem so this is a nice result by
McCoy Jeff McCarthy ov and B JA Raghavan
so in the multi way cut problem you're
given an undirected graph there edge
costs and there are K terminals
I think of K is like three if you want
and then what you would need to do is
you need to partition the graph so that
each of the terminals it's in is in its
own group and you want to minimize the
cost of the cut edges actually when K
equals two you'll recognize this just as
the normal St min cut problem in a graph
so zesty min cut but with more than two
terminals okay so you can again define
perturbation stable min multi-way cut
problems that just means that you know
the optimal solution again stays the
same under any of these perturbations
and you know one thing I meant to say
over here
is that notice that as we take gamma
bigger and bigger this condition gets
stronger and stronger the bigger the
gamma the more perturbations the optimal
solution has to survive that's harder to
do so we're talking about fewer
instances so the complexity of this
problem you know it's gonna be hard when
gammas 1 and as we jack up gamma you
might hope that it switches to
polynomial time solvable at some point
so the question I want to ask from in
multi way cut is what gamma is
sufficient for the multi way cut problem
to flip from being np-hard to being
polynomial time solvable so it's a
well-defined question and the theorem I
want to tell you a little bit about
shows that gamma equal four is
sufficient so if you have a four
perturbation stable min multi-way cut
problem that is the optimal solutions
invariant over multiplying each edge
cost by a factor between 1 and 4 then it
is no longer an np-hard problem it's
actually a poly time solvable special
case of min multi way cut
sufficient yes an open question is find
the threshold for Gama
but this is the best positive result
that we know it's definitely possible
you can still do it for smaller Gama
okay so I'm gonna have to the proof is
pretty cool but I'm gonna have to skip
it questions are more important than
proofs so but let me just say a couple
words to sort of intrigue the experts
for those of you that know some of this
stuff so the way I like to teach this
result is I first just review something
about the s T minimum cut problem which
has been known for a long time which is
if you write down a suitable linear
programming relaxation of the minimum
cut problem it actually just solves two
integers so even though in principle you
might be worried about getting a
fractional min cut back from your linear
program actually hands you an integral
minimum cut on a silver platter
okay so that's a property of the ST min
cut problem and you know this isn't you
know like shocking because you know it's
a polynomial time solvable problem right
I mean you could use max flow set if you
wanted instead to find a min cut you
don't need to solve an LP but actually
the exact same argument of how you prove
integrality of the s team and cut
relaxation can be used to prove this mmv
theorem okay so again the proof is going
to be the show that a suitable linear
programming relaxation is exact it
solves two integers okay so that's the
polynomial time algorithm again here's
where it's not tailored to the
assumption it's really just solve the
LPE
hope it works out and you get an
integral solution okay vm equals four is
sufficient for it to be true and so you
might be wondering about what is this
food but LP relaxation it's a it's a
famous one of kallen sq Karloff and
Rabbani
we're basically you embed each of vertex
into the simplex and the LP pays pays
according to one-half of the l1 norms if
you haven't seen it don't worry about it
not important if you have seen it then
this is to remind you and then you can
basically proceed as in the ST min-cut
case to show that it solves two integers
if it's for stable where is the four
come from well so there's a nice lemon
here where they use and again I want so
it's gonna be about a randomized
rounding algorithm but I want emphasize
remember this is gonna be using a
randomized rounding algorithm only in
the analysis right the algorithm is just
solve the linear program
and hope you get integers but in the
proof you actually use the existence of
a randomized rounding algorithm with
certain properties okay so it's an
algorithm due to climb Bergin Tardos
originally for metric labeling if you
haven't seen it don't worry about it
but basically you lose two factors of
two in different parts in the randomize
rounding algorithm of Kleinberg and
Pardo's and that's what gets absorbed by
the four in the perturbation stability
condition and once you have that idea
you literally write down just exactly
the same proof you'd write for exactness
of NTS team and cut and that gives you
the MMD theorem yeah kamesh
yes that's yeah that's sort of what the
proof does yeah yep
are you solving the problems exactly so
the LP is the exact right so feed in a
four stable instance and you will get
back a zero one solution and once you
get back a zero one solution from an LP
relaxation you of course know your
optimal question I'm not aware of one
but you're right it's a very natural
question the question was you know could
you could you imagine a definition where
rather than opt being invariant to all
perturbations in a certain range you had
you know invariant on average or in some
you know weaker sense I've never seen a
result like that but it would be nice to
see one no we know nothing in between
one and four and actually and so let me
let me use that to segue into kind of a
very general problem which I think is
really interesting right so what is the
alguns community been obsessed over for
like you know 30 years approximation
thresholds right you have an np-hard
problem and you know you know for a
sufficiently small it like for a one
approximation you know it's empty hard
you know if you think the approximation
ratio to be N or something big enough
it's almost all this poly time solvable
and so you look for the threshold where
does it switch from P to np-hard
so that's a threshold you can attach to
every optimization problem whenever you
have these stability notions not just
perturbation stability but also
approximation stability for example you
can do exactly the same thing you can
say I have an np-hard optimization
problem in general how big how strong do
I need to make the stability assumption
before recovery of an optimal solution
becomes poly-time solvable ok so let me
call that the stability threshold so we
have two with two thresholds for every
optimization problem an approximation
threshold and a stability threshold and
I would really like to have some
understanding of the extent to which
these two thresholds are related the
coolest result along these lines is
actually the main result from the mmv
paper which shows that there is a very
tight connection between these two
concepts but in different problems okay
the stability threshold for maxcut the
original bill you lineal setting
corresponds to the approximation
threshold for a different problem
sparse cut basically because what's
controlling both is low distortion
embeddings from l2 squared to l1
if you know what those are okay so
that's very nice there's a tight it's a
pretty tight connection between these
two thresholds and different problems if
you look at the two thresholds in a
common problem it seems to depend seems
like some problems approximations bigger
some perturbation the stability
thresholds bigger and sometimes they're
the same I'd love to understand what's
going on a little more deeply here
square root square root of log you know
kind of thing that's right yeah depends
on the graph size yes okay so last part
for part one and this will be this would
be quick so I'm gonna talk a little bit
about sparse recovery a huge topic
obviously I'll barely scratch the
surface so compressive sensing in
particular and what I'm sort of hoping
is that it at the moment it feels almost
jarring to you that I'm going from you
know clustering as hard only one doesn't
matter too sparse recovery you know an
area you've probably at least heard of
but associate with sort of different
communities largely and I'm putting
these next to each other because I want
to make it clear that the technical
statements the kinds of things you prove
is pretty much identical in these two
lines of work and this really should be
more opportunities for technology
transfer between the two areas so let me
just sort of review a famous result from
sparse recovery to say exactly what I
mean so there's a lot there's lots of
sparse recovery problems matrix
completion and so on I'm gonna look at
compressive sensing so this is the
problem of trying to recover an unknown
vector it's called the signal in this
context from linear measurements okay so
basically you're gonna be given an
underdetermined linear system and you
want to figure out what is this unknown
vector here for example maybe you're a
geophysicist you're looking for oil and
you want to know the structure of the
rock strata beneath where you are okay
because oil is likely to be a
discontinuities in the rock strata so
then when you're trying to learn X is
going to correspond to the structure of
the of the rock beneath you okay now
you'd love to just put a camera straight
down into the ground really far and see
what it is you can't do that so instead
you send seismic waves into the ground
and just to be clear
sending seismic waves is a euphemism for
blowing up a ton of dynamite okay so
that's what you do you blow up a bunch
of dynamite and you see what kind of
reflection do you get back of that
seismic wave okay so each of those each
of those seismic waves corresponds to a
linear measurement or a dot product so
that corresponds to a row of a with the
unknown signal and then you get back the
measurement the amount of the reflection
that you get okay
so again to be clear you know a you even
designed a you don't know X except in as
much as you know the inner products of X
with the rows of a as summarized in B no
you said you brought up at the ground
and then the waves go in isn't it just
like aren't you kind of thinking I
didn't know PNG physicists could be so
fun right okay so you know a your nature
gives you back B you want to know what X
is and you know notice that with no
further assumptions this is a totally
stupid problem this makes no sense okay
why well at least in the regime I'm
interested in where as suggested M the
number of rows is much less than the
number of columns now I mean it's an
underdetermined linear system you don't
have enough constraints to pin down all
the degrees of freedom and X so there's
gonna be a whole subspace of solutions
to this linear system I'm asking for
this specific one X how would you ever
know which point in the subspace it is
it's crazy
makes no sense so how can we make it
make sense the key idea is to assume
that the signal is the vector is sparse
okay so it has let's say only K non
zeros where K is much less than the
length n okay in practice it's usually
approximately sparse but the theory
extends to that and also maybe you know
it's not sparse in the standard basis
that spans sparse and some other and
other basis right so maybe the rock
strata are sort of sparse in the spatial
basis because there's not too many
discontinuities an audio signal is going
to be sparse and the Fourier basis so
image is going to be mostly sparse in
the wavelet basis and so on and the
theory works for all of these and so
that's the motivation behind the
sparsity assumption most signals are a
lot of signals that one cares about or
sparse in a suitable orthonormal basis
and once you make that assumption you
say well okay I have an idea to recover
X again remember you know a you were
given B you want to figure out X so
there's you look of course over the you
know subspace of solutions to this
linear system
and you say well if I know that the
solution is sparse let me just look for
the sparse just one in the subspace I'd
have to get like pretty unlucky for this
subspace to have two different super
sparse vectors so if I find a really
sparse vector probably that's the
unknown X I'm looking for okay
now problem is np-hard in general to
find the sparse a solution to a given
set of linear equations so we're gonna
look at a heuristic instead and just
like an in multi way cut our heuristic
is just going to be to solve a suitable
linear programming relaxation and hope
that it works so what is the linear
programming relaxation it's called l1
minimization so instead of instead of
minimizing the number of non-zeros you
minimize the l1 norm okay so over all
solutions to this set of linear
equations you find the solution with the
minimum l1 norm that can be written down
as a linear program you can solve it in
polynomial time now because this problem
is np-hard you know it's not always
going to work it's not okay sometimes
you'll get back something which is not
sparse it has non zeros everywhere and
they're just all really small numbers
and that's why you had l1 norm so are
there any interesting cases where it
does work under conditions on a for
example all right and this is exactly
what we were doing in multi way cut or
you wrote down a linear programming
allocation we know that in many cases
it's going to solve the fractions but is
there some kind of imposition on the
input which guarantees exact recovery
it's exactly the same thing you're after
here in compressive sensing and so you
know there's a bunch of guarantees of
this form for lots of different
algorithms but just to point out one so
under a condition on the constraint
matrix a then in fact it is if that's a
sufficient condition for recovery okay
so I'll say more about this in a second
but under a condition on a you solve the
linear program you get back actually the
sparse signal that you wanted all along
okay so what is the restricted isometry
property you know the details aren't
important you know it says something
like it approximately preserves the norm
of all case sparse vectors it's also
related to incoherence that's saying
that basically any pair of columns of
your matrix or approximately orthogonal
now if you've never seen this before
you're like is this a strong condition
is this a weak condition how should I
feel about this so one way you can
sanity check it is you can say well what
about a random nature
and you start feeling better about this
condition when you start realizing the
kind of from most models of random
matrices you're actually going to
satisfy this r.i.p condition with high
probability so in some sense it's a it's
a much weaker assumption than assuming a
random matrix it's assuming just this
deterministic condition which is implied
by random matrix models okay all right
and again you know I highlight this
because it seems you know there's a
beautiful and deep theory around sparse
recovery that's developed over the past
ten years I think there should be
opportunities to port more of those
techniques over to the combinatorial
types of problems that this crowd likes
to think about so that's that's that's
an opportunity so I'll leave the summary
on the board and I think we should break
we can talk about that I don't we can
talk about that there's a lot of really
nice techniques in smart recovery so
programming time algorithm so what does
it do it yeah what do you mean some of
the interior point methods I thought it
started without very compact again well
I guess the way I'm thinking of it as
you know so so you know if I look
downstream you know to who for whom with
this theorem be sort of illuminating I'm
thinking about someone who like bodice
license to suplex or you know has
installed an open-source LP solver on
their computer and you know they want to
have some understanding of whether it's
you know likely to be sufficient for the
problems that they care about or whether
they have to work harder or do something
custom and so this is saying you know if
you sort of believe that some kind of
stability condition is holding for your
instances actually with your cplex
license you're done okay so I'm sort of
thinking of linear programming for this
part as I saw as a well solved problem
not only well solved but well engineered
and implemented and available for anyone
demos so that's a good question so would
there be any reason to believe that
simplex would be polynomial time anyways
also under the stability condition no I
don't think anyone's thought about
trying to connect these stability
assumptions to running times they pretty
much only been looked at to analyze sort
of solution quality
the threshold or affirmation resilience
card should have the new paper on
archive which says that you can get to
perturbation resilience and use it about
kind of tell paper that's title what
problem are we talking about means
casein cool no I mean so I'm a high lead
one mmv paper but there's actually
they've done a lot of great work they'll
show up again in part two of the
tutorial this newest one I haven't seen
so thanks for letting me know